[Music]
is
[Music]
is
all right uh welcome to the second talk
today um and this is part one of a
double header with mark shandri from ntt
and princeton university unclonable
quantum cryptography so
i'll try and get the mic to you if you
have a question so everyone can hear it
and it gets registered on the
all video thank you
um
yeah so i'm today i'm just going to give
sort of a
a brief high level overview of
um sort of various aspects of quantum
photography where the the goal is to get
some sort of unclonability security
um
all right so the the starting point is
is naturally the quantum no cloning
theorem which says that if you have a
quantum state
uh but you don't know anything about it
you're just handed the quantum state
that you can't produce two identical
copies of that state
and you know contrast this to the
classical setting where information can
you know easily be copied just by you
know writing it down twice
um so the
the beginning of the field of quantum
cryptography is actually due to weisner
who said hey well if quantum states are
unclonable why don't we use them as
currency
um
so
right so you just your banknote is some
quantum state by the uncountability of
quantum states you now can't copy
your money
um
uh
right
so
then uh well i should say that uh
after after weinstein's proposal uh
quantum cryptography kind of went in a
different direction uh quantum key
distribution and stuff like that
um but
sort of in the last 10 to 15 years um
we've we've come back to thinking about
these uncountable problems
um so the the one that i'm going to be
spending the most time talking about um
is going to be public key quantum money
and this overcomes a limitation of
weissner's scheme
so the thing is that um
with with weisner's scheme the the
banknote is just this quantum state the
whole
uh reason that it's unclonable is that
the general public doesn't know what the
state is supposed to be
uh so then there's a question of how do
you actually verify your
you know someone someone hands you a
quantum state and claims it's a banknote
how do you actually verify that it was a
legitimate banknote
and um with wiser scheme there's no way
to do this the only thing you can do
basically is send send the money back to
the mint
uh they they will actually know what the
state was
and they can do they using that
knowledge they can check for you
uh but that's obviously not not
desirable you don't want every single
transaction that happens with your money
system to have to go through the mint so
really what you want
is
um a quantum state where it's unclonable
so it can be uh you know used as money
but you also want public verification so
that everyone uh
everyone has the ability to tell whether
they have the right quantum state
but uh still even with that ability they
can't uh copy it
and um a consequence of insisting on
public verification with no cloning
is that uh there's gonna be a cloning
aspect but there's also going to be a
computational security aspect and the
reason is if you were computationally
unbounded
and you had public verification so if
you're you're able to verify if you have
a quantum the correct quantum state but
you're also computationally unbounded
you can basically just do a brute force
search just just plug in an arbitrary
state uh run the verification see if it
see if it succeeds once it does you know
you have the the correct state
um so with public key quantum money we
enter this sort of interesting regime
where we're combining the information
theory that comes from quantum mechanics
with computational security
and this
uh this was really not a well-studied
area until you know starting starting
about 10 to 15 years ago
questions that combined
quantum with computational security
okay so in this talk i will give a
survey of the landscape of of basically
different cryptographic objects that
have this flavor of no cloning but also
seem to come
with a computational aspect and as we'll
see there there are so there are many
challenges to actually combining these
uh different uh
areas together
um so
i should mention that there there are a
lot of ways in which quantum uh
computational quantum information will
impact crypto and i'm not going to talk
about many of them um so i'm just here
just listing uh a couple impacts of
quantum for crypto that we won't be
discussing today
so one is uh you can improve the
assumptions needed for crypto there were
a couple recent works that um
were able to improve the assumptions
needed for secure multi-party
computation um from the classical
setting to something less uh
to basically the minimal assumption of
confidence setting
quantum presents many proof challenges
if your adversary is now a quantum
algorithm
uh
we we can't necessarily reason about our
quantum algorithms the same way we could
classically and there there are sort of
two main areas where this comes up one
is if your proof involves uh running the
adversary and then rewinding them
and it's now well known and this is this
has to do with the no cloning principle
um
but it's now well known that this is
problematic quantumly though uh we we
now have a good number of techniques for
how to
nevertheless do rewinding quantumly
um another one is this thing called the
random oracle model it's another proof
technique
used in classical cryptography and it
turns out when you sort of consider this
oracle classically you have to allow
quantum queries to the oracle and now
you know a lot of our classical proof
techniques break
uh and then finally uh
there's a class of attacks you might
call superposition attacks where the
uh you know something like a
pseudo-random function or or a signature
or something like that where the
adversary actually gets to you know
query the
challenger on a superposition of
messages instead of a single message and
this also breaks many of the proof
uh techniques yeah so i won't be talking
about these i'm really going to be
focusing on on no cloning
applications to
uh all right so so these are going to be
the kind of three broad areas i'll be
talking about today uh so the first is
public key quantum money uh and that the
publicly quantum money plus an aside
about uh the current state of
obfuscation uh will take up
i think the whole morning and then uh in
the afternoon i'll talk about the um
these other two copy protection and what
i'll call removable cryptography
okay
quantum money
um so our focus today is going to be on
something
um
called a mini scheme uh so when i talk
about uh quantum money i'm really just
gonna mean mini scheme this was a notion
coined by arizona
and really think of a mini scheme as
just a
a setting of quantum money where there
is just one bank note that's it one bank
note it has a serial number and and
nothing else
uh and
[Music]
uh unfortunately
uh we have uh anderson christiano proved
that uh with a mini scheme plus digital
signatures gives you a full scheme and
that this is uh
um i won't i won't really talk about
that it's not too hard um but really the
you know the so the bulk of of the
difficulty of getting a quantum money
scheme really boils down to constructing
a mini scheme
uh so what is a mini scheme uh so
there's there's two algorithms so
there's a gen algorithm that
samples a
banknote and a serial number for that
banknote
you can think of the serial number
as a public key i might call it that as
well
so you sample
so gen samples a
banknote and a serial number
and there
is just the verifier takes as input a
supposed bank note and the serial number
and either accepts or rejects
we have the obvious correctness
requirement that uh an honest banknote
serial number pair output by gen should
verify
and then we have the security over here
where the adversary is given the
banknote and serial number outputted by
jen
and what the adversary has to do is
produce two bank notes that each pass
verification with respect to the the
same series
right and so what we want is that
there's no computationally efficient
adversary that can can win this game
yeah is this reusable
uh
so i'm not going to stipulate it in the
definition but it it it turns out it is
it's sort of automatically reusable
because you can um
you know sort of once you have a
verification pass you actually know you
can implement your verification such a
way that it preserves the bank note this
is you know gentle measurement
so
uh yeah we don't we don't need to sort
of add that as a property that's
something you clearly want with your
money system um when you connect you get
it for free
if you implement bear the right way
okay um
so it turns out that there have been a
number of proposals for public key
quantum money in the in the last
uh i guess 13 years and the but really
they're best categorized as candidates
and the the reason is is that in in
pretty much all of these works their
construction is proposed and then
there's little dawn to um justify
the assumption other than like okay
maybe it's based maybe it's loosely
based on some problem that appears hard
classically maybe even one that's well
studied and believed to be hard
classically but there's no reduction
there's no proof that the
that the scheme is secure
if you know some widely believed uh
conjecture holds instead uh in most of
these cases
the
the scheme really just is conjectured uh
and then it's left to um you know
others to try to crypt analyze it
and um as a consequence it actually
turns out that a number of these
proposals have been broken
um
often
you know sometimes they require some
work sometimes uh
sometimes it happened really fast
and then other ones have have remained
um so so this one based on knox as far
as i know hasn't been cryptanalyzed but
there's also been
as far as i'm aware not a lot of
literature trying to trying to break it
um
there's some more recent construction
based on modular forms
and and then a
much more recent one based on quaternion
and algebras and really the the there's
been very little um
compared to like traditional
cryptographic assumptions like the
hardness of factoring there have been
very little work done trying to
analyze these schemes so i i don't know
i i mean
i did prove our scheme secure
yes
yes so so the one exception uh there's
basically two
exceptions to what i said about about
these schemes being uh not having
reduction so the erinson and christiano
scheme did in fact have
um a reduction i'll be talking more
about that
um and then there's uh i didn't put it
on here but um we can basically
instantiate the instant christiana
scheme and i'll talk about this more
later using a distinguishability
obfuscation and they're you know you
maybe you question the existence of
indistinguishability obfuscation but at
least there there's an assumption that
uh
might hold and we have a proof
okay so why why is quantum money so hard
i mean one might just be getting the
right structures in order to facilitate
uh quantum money seems challenging but i
think there's also
um sort of a more fundamental
reason why quantum money is harder at
least why building a quantum money
scheme with provable security is hard
and um and so here's here's kind of the
the first challenge
is okay suppose that i have a security
proof what does a security proof look
like i have some conjectured heart
problem it has to be quantum um hard or
believed to be quantum hard
um
it's something widely studied and by
just by the nature of you know the fact
that most cryptographers spent most of
their time in
the classical world um oh a hard problem
that's been widely studied is probably a
classically defined problem
um so it's you know it's a problem like
okay well factoring would be a bad
example but if a problem like cis or lwe
that has it's a classical statement and
you're just hoping that it's hard for
quantum uh attackers
um then you have a reduction and what
the reduction promises is to take any
adversary for the quantum money scheme
and
use it to solve the hard problem
so um
so why why does this present the problem
for quantum money well suppose i had
such a reduction
some quantum money scheme and such a
reduction
um well notice that we remember we said
that the hard problem is classically
defined which means that the instance of
the problem is actually a classical
string i can copy that i there's no it's
just bits right i can copy that as much
as i want
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take my hypothetical reduction and i'm
going to run it twice
on the
the same string
well what does the reduction spit out it
spits out it spits out an input to the
adversary for quantum money
what does the adversary get as input it
gets as input a banknote and a serial
number
so the reduction spits out a banknote
and a serial number
this reduction also spits out a banknote
in a serial number and now notice that i
have two banknotes
with respect to some serial number
and that's exactly what the reduction is
hoping to get from the adversary in
order to allow it to solve the heart
problem
so i just take my my first reduction up
there i i'm going to throw him away i
don't even need him anymore i just use
the fact that he span out a banknote in
a serial number i use that second copy
of the banknote and feed it into the
reduction down here
and by the guarantees of the reduction
it would seem uh the reduction you know
from the reduction point of view it
looks like it's interfacing with an
adversary for the quantum money scheme
so the reduction should actually break
the heart problem
right so
uh
right so this is um this is a sort of a
conceptual barrier to trying to
prove the the hardness of quantum or the
security of quantum money
um and i guess there's also another
conceptual barrier that's a bit more
high level which is that no cloning
comes from information theory right it
says if i give you an unknown quantum
state that you you can't clone it
on the other hand you know as we already
said the quantum money
state is actually information
theoretically cloneable from an
information theoretic perspective we
don't have no cloning it's it's totally
determined by the public key
and so somehow we need to combine
these information theoretic techniques
that allow us to prove something
unclonable
um
with the computational techniques of
reductions and and stuff like that in
order to take a state that is
information theoretically unclonable and
actually justif sorry information
theoretically cloneable and actually
justify that it is computationally
unclonable
um okay so so we we basically have three
strategies to do this right now um what
are the what are the strategies so so
the first is to
uh move into a relativized setting to to
assume that you have an oracle of a
particular structure
um and this was done by erinson and
christiano
um
and some of the some of the more recent
schemes also have um proofs relative to
oracles
uh so so the the pro here is that
relative to an oracle it turns out you
can actually get unconditional security
so um you know these schemes actually
have an unconditional security proof
that relative to this oracle they are in
fact quantum money secure quantum money
schemes
the
the the obvious problem though is that
uh you need to somehow actually
instantiate this oracle in the real
world
uh so this oracle might be very
structured so there's a question of even
how how might you find this structure
needed for the oracle in the real world
um
and then once you even if you have some
structure in the real world that sort of
mimics the oracle you have to justify
that it's as good as a black box that
essentially the only thing that an
adversary can do is query the
this function f on on various inputs or
superpositions of inputs
um
and not do something more more
sophisticated with with the non-black
box implementation
so we can get unconditional security but
it's it's not always clear how to get
this in the real world and and in
particular anton and christiano um so
they they they gave they gave oracles
they said it proves that you get
unconditional security and then they
gave a candidate implementation
um
which uh ultimately turned out it was
not as good as a black box and was
okay um so here's here's another
strategy
um that that
dates back to the work of uh ludomerski
and others
and then i kind of recoined the term a
couple years ago
and the idea is that well maybe i'll go
back to the the previous slide
um
so if we look here um i don't know if
anyone one caught what i did but i
cheated a little in the sense that i
assumed that the reduction both times i
ran it outputted the same serial number
right and um what if the reduction
outputted to serial number a different
serial number when i run it here and a
different serial number when i run it
down there
well then the the bank notes that i get
from the two runs of the reduction are
not valid with respect to the same
serial number
and so then then you know the the input
to the reduction down here will not
actually look like a valid adversary and
the reduction and the
um
this box here will not actually break
the heart problem
um
so so what we need then if we're going
to follow this kind of strategy what we
need is that the reduction that we have
outputs different serial numbers every
time we run it
um and and it's actually worse than that
it's not just that
a particular reduction we chose outputs
different serial numbers every time we
run it it's no matter what reduction you
could come up with
every time you run the reduction even on
the same classical string here you get a
different serial number so we're almost
thinking of the reduction as an
adversary now
and if you and if you formalize this
what you get is this thing called
quantum lightning where where so this
this uh this adversary now think of it
as the reduction
um the the adversary
or think of think of it as the sort of
running the reduction place i guess
um and it should be impossible for the
adversary to
come up with some serial number and two
banknotes that verify with respect to
that serial number
right so so if if we could say
that this was impossible for an
adversary to do this it would imply that
whatever reduction we chose must output
um
two different serial numbers every if i
run it twice
um
yes
uh yeah so it it it would
i mean we
it could be deterministic it could not
be deterministic um for for this kind of
approach it's sort of inherent that the
reduction would not be determined yeah
because otherwise
exactly right so it's sort of inherently
probabilistic um to the extent that
there's no way there's no way to run the
reduction deterministically no way to
you know like classically you could
always run the reduction
deterministically by fixing the random
points and here what we were saying
basically is no matter what you do to
run the reduction
it's always going to be randomized in
some way
um
right so so this is something called
quantum lightning and um
if you notice quantum mining is actually
stronger than quantum money so
in the in in this right right so in
quantum money it's the same goal of the
adversary except the adversary is told
what the serial number is supposed to be
um so in particular
uh
you know your adversary could just
honestly run the
generation algorithm to generate a
banknote and serial number and then and
then try to clone it
um and you know he chose the serial
number so he outputs it and uh
right now if you could do that that
would violate the security of of quantum
lightning so quantum mining is actually
a strengthening of quantum money
that says that you basically get this
unclonability property even if the
adversary generated the serial number
themselves
so in what sense is quantum lightning a
strategy to justify security a lot of
money
i mean it's it's not so much a strategy
it's just that you know in order to get
around this uh
this sort of conceptual barrier to
proving the securities wants money
this is a this is an approach you might
an approach you might take is trying to
design
a quantum money scheme where your
reduction has this property that it's
inherent
that it's sample that is sort of
probabilistic and i'm i'm still a little
unclear about what the conceptual
barrier was right i mean i mean you know
like like like sometimes you know we did
manage to prove the security of it you
know quantum money scheme you know value
of some reductions you know in our case
the the
problem reducing good good so it turned
out not to be hard but you know one you
know good so
it does work right so um i i
how did we get around this you got
around this by by using an atypical
modeling of uh security for that
cryptographers don't normally do
um right so so
so so
in your in your reduction yeah um it was
very sensitive to the running time of
the reduction in this reduction success
problem maybe not the running time but
certainly the success probability
it was you know um no no efficient
adversary can solve some problem with
probability more than a
you know some precise exponential
quantity that's right
right so if you had your i yeah we just
said you know we needed to make a strong
assumption about that you know that the
adversary could not even succeed with
this you know
large expert you know exponentially
small success problems right right so
the reason that that doesn't
so that that gets around this as well
um and the reason is that um
basically
what happens is because you're running
your reduction twice here you sort of
ample you're sort of amplifying that
exponentially small success probability
to the point where this reduction
actually doesn't qualify as an ad as it
will solve the problem but it won't
solve it with high enough probability to
qualify right okay um now with with
usual cryptographic modeling of of our
heart problems it's you know for all
polynomial time algorithms they have a
negligible probability and they're you
know multiplying you you get whatever
polynomial advantage your adversary had
you're going to square it but that's
still a polynomial so still so in that
case this this um this meta reduction
still counts as an adversary for p
whereas in your in your reduction this
meta reduction will actually not count
as an adversary for a figure
okay i'm still not clear what is this
picture supposed to illustrate it
supposed to illustrate that there cannot
be such a reduction like
uh yeah as well i mean it's there can be
as we're talking about on the next slide
but um it's illustrating a barrier to
coming up with a reduction because if
you could come up with such a reduction
then your heart problem is actually easy
you know uh
at least assuming your reduction has a
certain form okay all right all right
mark can you at least think what this
reduction is doing
right so the reason i i mean i don't
know what the reduction's doing it's
sort of a general reduction
but i'm just
my meta reduction is running the
original reduction twice on the same
challenge from the hard problem
the original reduction is is trying to
take a quantum money adversary and and
use it to solve the hard problem so it
supplies banknote and serial number to
an adversary gets two bank notes that
are supposed to be valid with that
serial number back and then based on
based on whatever it got back it's it's
trying to solve the hard problem over
here
so i have a dumb question here each
reduction is outputting two banknotes or
these are the two banknotes of one
each
introduction of putting a single
banknote um and then it expects to bank
notes in return
um this reduction i'm just going to
throw it away once i once i got my one
banknote and then this reduction i'm
going to feed the two banknotes from the
two different reductions into it
uh
right so
yeah i don't know if you if you want to
call this a strategy or another
primitive um sort of i talked about it
as uh i think both these words talked
about it as a
as a primitive but it's a it's a it's an
object that ends up being a
strengthening of quantum money but it
doesn't have this inherent barrier
or not inherent but it doesn't have this
uh supposed barrier um presentation i
mean
your quantum lightning paper did a huge
number of you know amazing things but
but but before that we had talked about
quantum money that you generate and you
know and you can't generate the same one
again right right so in what way is
quantum lightning different from that um
so
it's really the same thing um the prior
work never really formalized it um
okay
so uh yes are you claiming like formally
that if you want to have like a black
box reduction proof of security quantum
money you have to do the stronger thing
no no so the there's there's the white
spot spot here so there's one more tile
that i'm going to fill in
right
so before getting into that though i
wanted to mention an interesting open
question so i'm going to sort of
sprinkle this talk with open questions a
lot of them are actually broadly
accessible so even if you you know don't
like quantum you can still think about
some of these and
um
and if you solve these there's
interesting consequences
um so so here's an open question that if
you could solve would actually give you
quantum lightning and and therefore um
quantum money with uh
you know hopefully provable security
so uh what
you might call this a gap lwe so it's
going to look like learning with errors
uh but but
um
you know we're gonna add we're gonna add
something to it
so what i want
is some sort of distribution
over
uh tall skinny matrices
maybe with some auxiliary inputs
maybe not
so i want some some distribution over
over tall skinny matrices
uh and i want that
relative to this tall skinny matrix the
short integer solution is hard so so
you know if i have a tall skinny matrix
what is a short integer solution it's
you want to
uh find some vector uh
that's in the left kernel where the
vector's small so so my green vectors
here are going to be short vectors
in an l two and one
right so i want that cis is hard
relative to this distribution which
means if i sample an a from this
distribution i give you a i also give
you maybe some auxiliary information
about a that it should be infeasible for
you to
actually
uh solve cis
okay
uh so certainly so far this we we can do
this based on worst-case status problem
a is just a random matrix and
the auxiliary information is not
then you just get you just get plain old
cis
um the other thing i want is that search
lwe is hard uh so what is search lwe
it's i take a a random linear
combination of the columns and i add
some short error to that
um
and what's what the search version of
lwe says is we want they want you to
find
the
the secret s which is the linear
combination of the columns
um
right and again so far there's nothing
interesting or nothing you know new here
um
we you know a random matrix
also based on
worst-case lattice problems is the
search lwb is hard and actually in fact
um
you know regular's reduction um between
cis and lwe sort of allows you to
uh go between these or
in particular justify the hardness of
search of the we based on the hardness
of cis no matter what your distribution
over
okay and so here's where where things
are going to get interesting what i want
is that the decision version of lwe so
search is hard what i want is that the
decision version is easy so what is the
decision version it's i give you an lwe
sample
or i give you a uniformly random vector
and you have to decide which is the case
right so now now this is where things
get get interesting and we don't know we
don't know the answer right so we we
know that
um
we know that a random matrix a
all these problems are hard
um on the other hand how how do we
normally break uh
how in many cases we can give a trap
door for a that would allow you to break
decisional or even search lwe um but
those those trapdoors are just cis
solutions and so we need what we need is
some sort of way
of generating instances of of lwe where
the decision version is easy
um but that doesn't involve just like
you know making making uh cysts hard and
um through a quantum reduction that
would
doesn't involve making this easy
um or or search otherwise
the arc is just some kind of the win-win
so suppose that you this does not exist
does it have useful consequences
um it may be it's sort of related to
this notion of um sample preserving
source to decision reductions right so
um
you know we actually know for random
matrices how to go between search and
decision their their equivalent
um the the reductions though changed the
matrix a they sort of re-randomized the
matrix a
um and the initial reductions actually
also uh
expanded well expanded the matrix a and
made it bigger there was some work that
showed actually you can sort of preserve
the dimensions of the matrix a and still
get the search decision reduction to
work
um
and if you could if you could rule this
out basically
what it means is you actually have a
search to decision reduction that that
maintains the matrix a
itself
um
and i don't know that there's any
applications necessarily but it's uh
you know it might be an interesting
just tightening the connection between
crypto applications and coding uh theory
right because including theory they care
about the certain complications we
typically care about decisions
yeah yes i think it would be you know
either either way whether this exists or
not i think would would be an
interesting result um i'm not i'm not
aware of like
you know cryptographic applications of
of
of refuting this
random and just gave you access to an
oracle like get a trapdoor
lw with a particular a
i don't believe it's known
um
right and that that would yeah so so
uh
yeah i don't i don't believe it's known
uh yeah it might it might it's not
something i've really
thought about what are the uh
applications to sort of a negative
result here
but yeah uh yeah i i don't know this is
one of my favorite open problems um
i come up with an instance like this
um
[Music]
okay so
let's get back to our strategies to
justify security
um so the the last strategy that we know
um
is the following
we're actually
going to
not care so we're going to actually say
that our reduction doesn't care so much
about
the the cloned quantum money state it
got from the adversary but really all
it's going to care about is the fact
that the adversary cloned
um some put maybe a little more
uh or to put in other words what we're
going to imagine is we we have the
there's some real world where we have
you know our public key and
you know the adversary is given a
quantum money state etc
and then there's going to be some some
fake world
and in the fake world
um if cloning is actually going to be
information theoretically and feasible
so think about like there are certain
like fake public keys
uh relative to which uh cloning is
information theoretically infeasible
um and what the reduction is basically
trying to do is just tell which world
they're in
um
and so in in this case the reduction
might actually have the ability to clone
states the reduction itself might have
the ability to clone states as much as
it wants
um but the adversary in one case will be
able to clone and in another case won't
be able to clone and that that
that is going to allow the reduction to
distinguish the
um
the two cases and and solve its problem
what's the one known instance of this
um
so uh the one known instance is this is
how um i was able to prove that the
erroneous cristiano quantum money scheme
was secure if you used
indistinguishability obviously
uh so so in order to give the the gist
of that i'll i'll first describe the
interesting christian quantum ministry
uh so the central object in the scheme
is there are the subspace states so a is
some linear subspace of let's say half
the dimension of the ambient space
and the
banknote is going to be the
superposition over all vectors in that
subspace
the serial number
i'm going to change this in a moment but
the serial number for now think of it as
just the description of the subspace and
also the dual subspace
uh
you know so
certainly you can go from a to a perp
and back but uh we'll see why i wrote
these down separately in a moment
um
and then how do i verify banknotes so
the first thing vera does is it first
checks that the quantum money state
actually has all of its support in the
subspace a and this is just a classical
test run in superposition
um so this this is easy enough to do
when you're given a
and then uh well i should say if you
stopped here uh your verification
succeeds but you don't have any security
because any any classical string in the
subspace a would also pass verification
and you can obviously copy
um any classical string as much as you
want so this this isn't enough for
security and so what you do
is you do the quantum fourier transform
if you have the right quantum money
state
uh it turns out that the fourier
transform uh gives you another subspace
state but it's a subspace state for the
dual
um and so you can just use your
knowledge of a perp to check that your
support is in fact
all contained in the dual space
and then you just do a qft back in order
to get your quantum members
um
right so so this is this is the
um
this is the proposal
now as stated right now it's totally
insecure uh because the serial number if
public tells you what a is and given a
you can just use uh like basic linear
algebra to construct the subspace states
um
so
what what erinson and christiano propose
is that well actually you know in order
to do verification i don't need to know
the subspace i just need to be able to
test membership in the subspace a and
membership in the duel
so you know why don't we why don't we
obfuscate them in some way um so
obfuscate membership in a office escape
membership in april
and the hope is that we obfuscate it in
a way that some somehow you know
hides the subspace and in particular
prevents you from
actually constructing subspace states
and then what are some questions to do
is they prove they prove in a black box
model that that in fact this is secure
unconditionally
and also gave the the candidate
instantiation
um
right so
the the question i guess
is what kind of security you know forget
oracle's for now um if i were going to
implement this using some sort of
standard model obfuscation scheme
uh
what is the security property that we
need out of it
um
and you know maybe there's many security
properties that would work
uh but here's one that's certainly
sufficient so it's something that i'll
call subspace hiding obfuscation
the here's here's here's what the
um
security
stipulates it says okay first choose a
random
subspace b of of some dimension i'm
going to be kind of hand-wavy about the
dimensions um
so first choose a random subspace b
and then choose a random subspace of b
and call it a
and what i'm going to give to the
adversary
is either so i'm always going to give
the adversary a
and then i'm either going to give an
obfuscation that test membership in a or
an obfuscation a test membership
and what we want is that these two
worlds are indistinguishable
right so um so this is the you know the
definition of subspace hiding
obfuscation
and then if you have subspace hiding
obfuscation uh that's actually enough to
instantiate the unseen christian quantum
money scheme
um how do you do it so or what's the
what's the proof look like so in the
proof or okay so here's the your honest
uh
quantum money uh serial number and
remember the the bank note is the
subspace state for a
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
use the subspace hiding obfuscation
security
to define a uh you know a fake world or
an imaginary world where i my my public
key actually is obfuscating some super
space of a i'll call it s and also
obfuscating some super space of a perp
call it t
you know
when you
say i mean so so the the adversary so
the adversary is trying to distinguish
two values what are the values are these
pairs one
i don't know just in the clear in the
clear just written as bits
exactly so through some instead of some
bases you actually specify what a is yes
yes some some compact representation
exactly
and yeah the reason a's here is
basically so there's kind of two
obfuscations going on right there's one
for a and one for a perp and so in order
to maintain security of of the pair of
them you need some sort of composability
of this definition and having a
uh sticking around uh right right the
the quantum money adversary is never
given a but we need our reduction to be
able to actually um
in order for our reduction to actually
work we we need the reduction to know
what a is
um
right so so what happened so we're going
to define this fake world where instead
of an obfuscation of a in an obfuscation
of a perp i give you an obfuscation of s
and an observation of t where s is a
super space of a
and t is an object a superspace of apart
and the
um
what's crucially important here is that
the
when i do this in this fake world the
verification of the adversary's forgery
is still with respect to the and ana
perp so i give you i give you
obfuscations of s and t but then i'm
asking you
without you don't know a and i'm asking
you to come up with a subspace state
that
is valid with respect to a and a perp
um so
so
these are these are the two worlds and
in this fake world
you the adversary just information
theoretically doesn't know a anymore
they they know a superspace of a in a
super space of a perp but there's some
uncertainty from their perspective about
what a is and it's information theoretic
uncertainty
and yet they somehow have to clone
a state with respect to a and a perp and
it turns out now you can just use
you can in fact use information theory
and show that this is just
unconditionally
hard to clone in the in this fake world
um but then
you can use the
security of the obfuscators the subspace
hiding obfuscation to say that the fake
world and the real world are
computationally indistinguishable and
now you you're
you have your security proof
so if you could if you could forge in
the
in the real world you can forge in the
fake world
but that is unconditional unconditional
impossible
right so so this is basically the the
only other way we know how to justify
the security of
uh the quantum money is is true
um
so now i guess the obvious question is
oh i should also point out that in the
reduction so the reduction is
um trying to distinguish between the
real and the fake world in the in the
reduction the reduction knows a and the
reduction knows a in order to actually
implement the verification so it knows a
in order to come up with the bank note
that the adversary sees in the first
place and then also needs to know a in
order to implement the verification
um and so because it knows a can it can
clone all at once
but the point is it knows that the
reduction
sorry it knows that the adversary
doesn't know a
and all it's using in order to tell
whether it's given an obfuscation of ana
for notification of smt
all it's using is the fact that in one
case the adversary
uh
clones and in the other case it doesn't
and that's how that's how it
doesn't care again it doesn't care what
the clone is it's not really using
anything about the clone just the fact
that the adversary cloned in the first
place
ultimately not information theoretically
you know if you could violate things
yeah the ultimate proof is
it's information theoretic in the fake
world but the fake world the fake world
is not publicly quantum money because
you need a and a perp in order to verify
um okay and then so you're using
computation to just go between the fake
and the real world
um all right so so this um
gives me the the second open question
which is
um can you construct subspace hiding
obfuscation from standard post quantum
assumptions so we actually know how to
do this from um ddh it's not hard um
but you know the ddh
is broken by schwarz algorithm and so
the question is can you you know from
lattices lpn uh you know whatever your
favorite post quantum assumption is can
you construct subspace hiding on the
station
i mean what was it specifically about
the subspace scheme that let you use i o
like would i have also worked for other
quantum publication
no
not not obviously um
yeah so um
you know in the last 10 minutes i was
actually going to segue to talking about
what we know about obfuscation um i
won't really address that all right we
should talk about it later yeah i mean i
don't really address how the proof goes
it's sort of it is it is very particular
to the subspace okay um
okay
yeah so i wanted to conclude the morning
talk with um a detour into
um obfuscation and
uh you know what what do we know about
obfuscation
the reason i want to do this is because
obfuscation you know obfuscation became
a central object in in classical
cryptography
and for for quantum cryptography and all
these unclonable concepts that we'll be
talking about
in many cases the only way we know how
to um
justify the security of our
constructions is if they're based on
obfuscations so
um
you know it seems like an important
thing to
make sure without quantum leap
um so obfuscation oxidation is a really
old concept uh dates back you know many
decades
and and there's there's a lot of what
i'll call ad hoc obfuscation
schemes out there and they just do sort
of you know uh um
[Music]
you know simple
uh transformations on program code
where they you know i don't know insert
or remove white space reorder operations
insert dummy operations stuff like that
um and adaha this adult obfuscation
gives gives software that's you know
impossible to read for a human
um but it turns out in most cases with
with
enough effort you can actually sort of
understand what the program is doing and
recover something resembling the
original program and so uh we like to
think of ad-hoc confiscation as more of
a speed bump it's not really
um secure in the usual cryptographic
sense of uh
polynomial time
adversaries
um
and then we have a more recent object
that i'll call mathematical obfuscation
and here we're really doing
transformations at sort of a
mathematical level or circuit level um
and you know so here's a picture like
one of the early approaches to
mathematical obfuscation was to use
barrington's theorem to write things as
a matrix branching program then you like
do algebraic transformations on the
matrix branching program um
and
mathematical interest obfuscation turns
out actually gives us very strong
guarantees assuming it exists um and
because of this it's become a central
object in theoretical cryptography
theoretical because
as the cryptographers know we're
very far out in theory
um
so
unfortunately though
even if you have the best off new skater
in the world
um there are just some programs that
can't be obfuscated so this you know
even before we had mathematical
obfuscation barack will show that there
are some programs that cannot be
obfuscated and the rough idea is that
they sho they came up with programs
where if you run the program on its own
code or any actually in fact any if you
run the program on any code for the
program um it'll spit out the original
program so my fuzzy uh programs there i
mean it was obfuscated and hear the the
unfuzzy ones
um so i i should mention that i'm not
going to formally define what it means
to be obfuscated um
but uh the the point is that there are
some programs out there that you know
this clearly violates anything you would
want
and and as such uh
you know we have to settle for something
that isn't isn't optimal
in terms of security and that's in
distinguishability obfuscation which
says that if i give you two programs
that compute the same functionality
uh then i hope that their obfuscations
are indistinguishable computationally
um the problem with indistinguishability
obfuscation or io is that
what does it mean in terms of i you know
i have some program uh
you know maybe you know the original use
of occupation before photographers got
their hands on it was to you know
protect intellectual property and
software so i have my program i have
some intellectual property in it i want
to protect what does it mean to
obfuscate it with io i don't know you
know in order to dem in order to
demonstrate anything with io you need to
exhibit two programs that are
functionally the same
um and i have my one program i i don't
know like how do i find out another
program that computes the same thing and
even if i do the fact that they're
indistinguishable what does that tell me
about the protection of my international
property i don't know
um
so io doesn't really have a meaningful
guarantee on its own though we do know
if a program p can be obfuscated by any
pro by any obfuscator i o is good enough
um
those are shown by goldboss
rothbloom so um you know in some sense
io is and they they coined this term
that i o is the best possible active
skater uh but that still doesn't really
answer the question of
you know what are the gear like
when can a program be obfuscated
um
so
um
sort of a big change happened um in 2013
with the first proposal of mathematical
obfuscation
and then there were tons of words i
can't i can't possibly summarize that
would be a whole talk on its own
um but sort of the the main things for
for us today are that um a couple years
ago there was this breakthrough work by
jane lynn and sahai that showed how to
build i o
from
somewhat standard tools
except the pre-quantum the the tools
they use do not have or at least one of
the tools they use does not have
um
security against quantum attackers so in
the in the classical world we actually
have you know pretty compelling
constructions of i
in
o
quantum world uh things are not as good
but they're okay
um so we have a few works that have
proposed constructions of io
um and these are these are really
candidates um but they have they have
been analyzed there's been a number of
works
trying to justify the security of these
um
and they're
you know they they plausibly are
postponed
what they make that what makes them a
candidate and not like uh
these constructions are all based on
lattices but we don't know how to prove
their security relative to anything any
like assumption that people have made on
lattices
um
i think i think these recent works
actually do boil down the assumption to
something like really
nice and and
easy to think about but
um they're certainly non-standard
um
and this one is just purely a candidate
it's just you know here's a construction
that we don't know how to break
okay so so you know we have in the in
the pre-quantum setting we have you know
these pretty convincing i o
constructions in the post quantum
setting we have ones that are uh seem
quite plausible but you know maybe a
little uncertain
and then the sort of the other thing
that's happened in the last 10 years is
we have basically developed a number of
techniques for using io to
actually justify
uh the occupation of specific programs
so basically there's been all this work
on using io to solve certain
cryptographic tasks
and the way it works is that you know
basically they design a particular
program and then you know more or less
prove that it can be obfuscated with i o
and that gives you
uh a lot of cryptographic applications
um you can't see
um so there's a giant oval here
on the screen okay good um so there's a
giant there's a giant oval here uh of
all classical programs
and we know that there are some that are
unobfuscatable
um just
you know unconditionally
and then we have uh you know provably
obfuscatable programs on the other end
of the spectrum and sort of everything
in between we don't really know
um and you know it's a pretty vast
area in between
uh
and then if we sort of if we zoom in on
what we know how to obfuscate
uh there's there's basically four pieces
so
down here are learnable programs by
learnable i just mean given um oracle
access to the program you can recover
the program
um
these are trivially obfuscatable just in
the sense that
um you can just output the program in
the clear and it's sort of
it meets our definition of obfuscated in
the sense that anything you can learn
from
oracle access you can also learn from
the program code
vice versa anything you can learn from
the program code you can learn from
oracle access because oracle access
gives you the program code
so these are sort of trivially
obfuscatable
um
and then um
what we what we know from
uh you know the last 10 years of work on
applications of io is we know how to
obviously get a lot of cryptographic
programs
um but
uh and we also know how to oxidate
evasive programs so invasive program or
some invasive programs evasive programs
are those that um
basically are
um
you know the set of inputs that are
accepting are very sparse
um and any particular input is
unlikely to have um caused the program
to accept so things like point functions
and whatnot um so we we have we have uh
for a lot of evasive programs we know
how to obfuscate them
and then there's basically a little
sliver of things that we know how to
obfuscate that aren't learnable
cryptographic or evasive
and that's exactly where subspace hiding
obfuscation comes in so it's non-evasive
because you're given
that you remember you're given the the
subspace a and you know all inputs in a
will be accepted so you can always find
accepting inputs to your obfuscated
program and yet you're still hoping for
some level of security um so it's it's
not evasive it's also not cryptographic
it's just hyper planes um there's not
you know it's not like you're obviously
getting prfs or anything
by a cryptographic program do you mean
one for
like a prf yeah and wait i know this
could be obfuscated why well okay i
actually not all cryptographic programs
can be obfuscated the the you can come
up with prs that cannot be but many
cryptographic programs can um if they're
designed carefully and this this was
sort of
you know essentially the the last 10
years of work on applications of io has
you know what they've shown is how to
design programs that can be obfuscated
and they all tend to be cryptographic
all right thank you
and here when we
scale
i'm being very imprecise um
you know like subspace hiding
obfuscation is not actually as strong as
bbd
is stronger um
i i yeah i i don't really have but i
don't really have a precise definition
of what i mean by can be awkward but
think vbd
or related things
right but the point the point i guess is
that i o on its own doesn't say anything
like i can io any program but that
doesn't imply anything is hidden about
the program what i mean by uh what i
mean by these is that something is
hidden about the program given
something
on the barrier non-trivial
it is a force of space height
infrastructure that's invasive right
i might actually be right
i don't remember
if their work
considers any setting that's
non-invasive yeah
it's just extensional point functions so
that you cannot really know the subspace
but they put some sort of vbb
and if if the vbb is with auxiliary
information then
they're probably
if it's not invasive then it's learning
uh no subspace is not though okay so so
i don't know i don't know what uh
you can make membership
[Music]
um sure but think of it like the you
know the dimension of the subspace is
like half or two-thirds of the overall
dimension and it's sparse
but you might be given side information
that tells you accepting inputs
right so in that sense it's not evasive
anymore that you're given you're given
you're given accepting inputs and but
what you still want is some security for
the points that you don't know
right
so it's it's very close to an evasive
function but it i i guess i don't
consider it evasive
um
and for example you know in here in this
group here we actually can we can
obfuscate um subspaces using computing
compare objection we can obfuscate
subspaces if you're not given anything
about the subspace
right but once you once you once you
throw in the fact that you're actually
given
a smaller
subspace explicitly in the clear of
inputs that are accepting then we don't
know how to do this from
from
other than bios
so the two notions of some space of uh
hiding or flusteration is different in
general
yeah i mean i don't yeah i don't
remember exactly what they prove i i
thought that there's would have
encompassed subspace hiding occupation
but certainly it it's it's kind of a
trivial proof that proves that ddh gives
you subspace hiding obfuscation
right you just have a matrix whose
kernel is your subspace
and it's really easy
so what they what they prove what they
what they prove allows you to
do
it it's it's
maybe it's incomparable to subsidies
hiding obfuscation but it's certain um
it's some sort of dvd notion that that's
a stronger security property
if you can get the notion of some
society and frustration that you need
for quantum money from groups isn't that
strictly better
well the groups are quantum so you don't
you don't get a secure quantum money
scheme
okay uh yeah so um i should mention that
i i
i'm not claiming that there's nothing
else in this little sliver here but um
i'm i'm actually not aware of anything
or maybe i just forgot and i was aware
um but i i i you know
if there's anything else um that's that
we know how to obfuscate it's not
cryptographic non-evasive um
uh
and
this leads me to my the third open
question which is all right i i feel
like the the non-evasive
non-cryptographic setting is actually
um for the original motivation of
obfuscation of you know protecting
intellectual property that is the
setting that you're usually in right my
whatever software i develop is probably
non-invasive otherwise it's not
particularly useful
um and it's probably not cryptographic
in nature um
and
so
uh sort of finding more ways to justify
the
that you can securely obfuscate
non-invasive non-cryptographic programs
um this is like a pretty open-ended
question but i i think this is a very
interesting one
um
just like understanding
um
so uh let i'll just uh
so the takeaways here are that yeah we
have somewhat compelling pre-quantum io
we have good candidates for post quantum
io but you know
their status isn't quite as good
then we have a good understanding about
the guarantees of io for some
cryptographic or evasive programs but
um you know not a lot not a lot else um
yeah and we have we have yeah this
really is not not a great understanding
of
what what you can um
obfuscate securely even if you had i o
what you cannot escape securely in the
non-crypto or non-invasive setting
um
so i think with that uh
i'll i'll stop the the morning talk so
we've talked about quantum money um
and now uh in the afternoon we'll we'll
talk about copy protection and revocable
cryptography and the you know everything
about obfuscation that we've talked
about will be relevant for copy
protection as well
i'll leave it here and we'll come back
later
so
[Music]
all right so we will
see that one